الموقف الروسي طاهر لن يكون متساهلا
بالتاكيد انها سرقه بهذه الكلمات ردت
موسكو على المقترحين الامريكي والاوروبي
بالاستيلاء على الاموال الروسيه المجمده
المتحدث باسم الكربلاند اعتبر ان
الاحتياطات والاصول الروسيه في الدول
الغربيه سرقت بالفعل واضاف ان سرقه
ممتلكات روسيا في الخارج تنتهكوا جميع
القوانين والاعراف اما بانك روسيا فقد بدا
اكثر واقعيه معتبرا ان فرصه دول الغربيه
في اعاده الاصول الروسيه المجمده بسبب
العقوبات منخفضه للغايه موسكو اكدت انها
لن تقف مكتوفه حياله اي اجراء يتخذه
الاتحاد الاوروبي رئيس البرلمان الروسي في
الاسلام فولودين دخل على الخط محذرا الدول
الغربيه من مصادرتي اصول روسيا كما قال
انه في حال مصاد الاصول فان لروسيا الحق
في اتخاذ اجراءات مماثله تجاه الدول التي
ستتخذ هذه القرارات هذا الاهتمام بالاصول
الروسيه يعكس قيمتها الضخمه فوفقا للارقام
المعلنه من الاتحاد الاوروبي فقد تم تجميد
حوالي 300 مليار يورو من احتياطات البنك
المركزي الروسي وذلك في اطار العقوبات
التي فرضتها اوروبا على موسكو بسبب
العمليه العسكريه على اوكرانيا كما تم
تجميد تسعه عشره مليار يورو من اموال
الاوليغارش الروسيه
[موسيقى]